our universe was created about 13.8
billion years ago in the Big Bang but
first it was very simple consisting of
little more than hydrogen and helium and
lots of energy there were no stars or
galaxies no planets and certainly no
living creatures then gradually more
complex things appeared the first stars
and galaxies probably appeared within
about 200 million years of the Big Bang
as big stars lived and died they blew up
and created new elements those new
elements allowed the creation of new
materials such as the dust and ice and
rocks and minerals from which planets
are made our Sun and solar system
appeared about 4.5 billion years ago and
by four billion years ago it's likely
that life had emerged on earth life
evolved and diversified but most of it
consisted of tiny single-celled
organisms until about 1 billion years
ago the first many celled organisms
appeared from about 500 million years
ago big creatures became much more
common from trilobites to trees to
Tyrannosaurus Rex the first humans
evolved very recently just about 200,000
years ago though it wasn't obvious at
the time the appearance of humans turned
out to be hugely important because
humans were able to share ideas and
information better than any other
species that ever existed using that
ability
our ancestors gradually built up stores
of information that allowed them to
control our environments more and more
powerfully the process accelerated until
in just the last hundred years we have
become so powerful that what we do in
the next few decades will determine the
future of the oceans the climate and of
most other species on earth including
our own descendants
many scholars believe that this
represents a new geological epoch the
Anthropocene in the last 50 years we
humans have begun to control energy and
resources on such a vast scale that
we're transforming the land the seas and
the atmosphere of the earth
so planet Earth is at a turning point in
its history humans now the dominant
species will either lead the biosphere
towards a flourishing future or to
catastrophe
perhaps triggered by nuclear wars that
could ruin swathe for the planet in just
a few hours or caused or slowly by the
continued release of greenhouse gases
until the land is flooded and global
climates are too hot to grow in our food
this is a very very big deal never
before has a single species determine
the future of the entire biosphere the
good news is that we understand the
science and we already have many of the
technologies needed to build a
sustainable future what's missing now is
the political technology how can
government's and people's be encouraged
to see the challenges that they all
share rather than simply defending their
own local and immediate interests only
by collaboration can we avoid the many
dangers we face today so here's the once
in a four billion year life challenge
can we steer planet Earth towards a
prosperous future in which humans and
all the other organisms on which we
depend can flourish for thousands even
perhaps for millions of years into the
future
you